في خطوه اعتبرت لمواجهه زياده النفوس
الصينيه في المحيطين الهند والهادئ بدا
اجتماع ثلاثي جمع قضت الولايات المتحده
وبريطانيا واستراليا هدف لوضع لمسات اخيره
على صفقه الغواصات النوويه التي تنمي
كمبرا الحصول عليها ضمن التحالف الامنيه
المعروف حيث صرح مسؤول امريكي ان استراليا
تنوي شراء ثلاثه غواصات نوويه من واشنطن
وتدرس شراء اثنتين اخرتين فيما قال البيت
الابيض ان الولايات المتحده واستراليا
وبريطانيا ستتعاون لبناء جيل جديد من
الغواصات العامله بدفع النووي تهدف الدول
الثلاث لتبادل المعلومات الاستكبارات
الاستخباراتيه فضلا عن تزويد استراليا
بصواريخ كما تامل دول ثلاث تعاون في مجال
الصواريخ الفرد صوتيه وذكاء الاصطناعي
والحرب الالكترونيه